In the months leading up to the release of
Star Wars: The Force Awakens, fans spent a
lot of time theorizing about what might happen
in the new film.
When they finally got to see the movie, they
discovered that there was still plenty left
to be discussed, as not all the questions
initially posed were answered.
Moviegoers are now beginning the wait for
Episode 8, and they’re going back to what
they do best: speculating about Star Wars.
Here are 10 amazing Star Wars: The Force Awakens
Theories That Change Everything.
Han Solo Is Still Alive
For longtime fans, it was very heartbreaking
to see iconic character Han Solo meet his
noble end, being murdered by his own son.
Understandably, they don’t want to think
about future Star Wars without Han, so some
have hoped that Solo lived through the fateful
encounter.
After all, Darth Maul was cut in half and
was later revived in the animated Clone Wars
series, so why can’t something similar happen
for Han?
Unfortunately, it’s just wishful thinking.
Not only did the planet blow up, Han’s death
was the key emotional moment of Episode 7,
and Lucasfilm won’t want to undermine that.
There’s a reason Harrison Ford isn’t in
the Episode 8 cast.
Snoke Is A New Character
People have been trying to figure out the
true identity of Supreme Leader Snoke – but
what if it’s just Snoke?
One theory suggests that Snoke is an entirely
new character, not Darth Plagueis or another
reincarnated Sith.
The Sith thrive on emotion and attachments,
using the Force to serve their personal needs.
This goes against Snoke’s teachings to Kylo
Ren, where he tells his apprentice to purge
sentiment and emotion.
Snoke feels the Empire fell because Darth
Vader loved his son, and if the Dark Side
is to prevail, something like that cannot
happen again.
This would make Snoke something completely
new to the films, a welcome development.
Kylo Ren Saved Rey
Ben Solo destroyed the Skywalker family when
he turned to the Dark Side, but he still has
a soft spot in his heart.
Some think that Kylo Ren is the one who took
Rey to Jakku where she would be safe.
In Rey’s Force Vision, there’s a part
where Kylo stabs someone about to attack Rey,
suggesting he may have saved her during an
assault.
Kylo is also very interested in Rey throughout
the film, asking “What girl” when told
of her involvement with BB-8 and asking to
be her teacher in the ways of the Force.
The novelization implies he knows her, and
this would be an interesting dynamic.
Rey Solo
The biggest mystery fans want solved is who
Rey’s parents are, and some think that there’s
still a chance she’s Han and Leia’s daughter.
Once Kylo Ren turned to the Dark Side, Han
and Leia went their separate ways, and only
after did Leia discover she was pregnant again.
She kept Rey a secret from everyone and hid
her on Jakku for safety.
The age gap between Kylo and Rey makes this
a possibility, and it would explain why Han
doesn’t recognize Rey when he first meets
her.
Still, in their interactions, Han and Leia
only discuss Ben – so this one is probably
just a stretch.
Vader’s Helmet
Kylo Ren is very fond of his grandfather,
and even keeps Darth Vader’s helmet in a
personal chamber to commune with in times
of need.
The connection between the two villains is
very interesting, and some think the helmet
was what swayed Ben Solo to the Dark Side.
In Star Wars canon, the Force can embed itself
into objects, so it’s possible that the
helmet of a Sith Lord is covered in darkness
and can leave a strong impression on a troubled
young apprentice.
It would explain the strong bond between Ren
and Vader and why Kylo asks the helmet to
show him the power of the Dark Side again.
Luke and Leia’s Sibling
Could there be another Skywalker?
That’s what the opening text crawl in Episode
7 wants you to believe.
One line says that Leia is desperate to find
her brother Luke, without commas around the
name Luke.
According to grammar rules, there should be,
since “Luke” is not essential to the meaning
of the sentence, just “brother,” unless
there’s a third Skywalker sibling viewers
don’t know about.
It’s most likely this is just a typo that
slipped by editing, but there’s no denying
it would be one hell of a twist if it proved
to be true.
Rey’s Force Training
Some fans found it too convenient that Rey
as able to display such adeptness with the
Force as Episode 7 progressed since she had
no prior training – or did she?
Some theorize that Rey was a student of Luke
Skywalker’s before Ben Solo went bad, and
whoever hid Rey wiped her memory so she forgot
her previous teachings.
As Rey embarks on her adventure, the lessons
come back to her and she’s able to use powerful
Force abilities.
This would explain a perceived problem with
the film, but even if it’s untrue, it’s
no big deal.
Luke was able to blow up a Death Star with
the Force, after all.
Han Killed Himself
Though it’s suggested Kylo Ren murdered
Han Solo, both had their hands on Kylo’s
lightsaber before it was turned on.
One theory says that Han was the one who put
the blade through his chest, realizing that
the Dark Side had taken over his son and knowing
what was about to happen.
In an effort to save Ben from one more sin
tying him to evil, Han decided to take his
own life and spare his son the pain.
This would make the scene even more emotional,
but the look of sheer surprise on Han’s
face illustrates he was not expecting to die
in that moment.
He just wanted his son back.
Rey Skywalker
The most common belief about Rey is that she
is the daughter of Luke Skywalker, and the
film does enough to support it.
The Skywalker family lightsaber specifically
calls out to her, and Rey is already strong
with the Force – just like Anakin and Luke.
The film’s script also implies that Luke
recognizes Rey when they meet at the end,
suggesting Rey is not just an average inhabitant
in the galaxy.
The numbered episodes are said to be a generational
tale of the Skywalker family, so Rey being
Luke’s offspring adds up.
Seeing a Jedi train his own daughter sounds
very compelling, so fingers crossed for this
one.
Kylo Ren: Double Agent
What if Kylo Ren’s mission isn’t to consume
himself in the darkness, but rid the galaxy
of it?
Some think that Ben Solo is working as a double
agent to destroy the Dark Side from within,
leading to his conflicted feelings.
This would explain he was so emotionally torn
after killing Han Solo, having sacrificed
his loving father for the greater good to
show his allegiance to the Dark Side.
This would put an intriguing spin on things,
giving greater depth to an already intriguing
character.
The evidence supporting it now is slim, but
there are still more movies to come.
As unlikely as it seems, this would be a great
twist.